newlyweds Sarah Hyland and Wells Adams
modern families Jesse Tyler Ferguson was
their officiant and our Lauren zema got
some exclusive details on the I Do's I
knew that Sarah and Wells wanted it to
be a funny like lighthearted ceremony
um they're not serious people that was
your first time doing it right my first
time officiating
um I don't know if a lot of people know
this but tyborough was meant to do it
and there was a family emergency so I
got a phone call 12 days before the
wedding everyone was invited not
everyone could make it
um but I was like well no pressure it's
my first time I was so honored to do it
and very happy to understudy Ty Burrell
with all the fans love seeing that many
Modern Family Reunion what were some of
those moments we didn't see on social
media she didn't see us all getting
drunk out of our minds on social media
which is for the best Julie bone was
acting crazy and she was like showing my
son how she can eat off of a plate like
a dog without using his hands like stop
it stop it
[Music]
where is the Modern Family reboot I
don't know there is an idea out there
and maybe it'll come to
might one day I don't know for now
Jesse's channeling his inner ballet
teacher for Ivy and Bean a new Netflix
film series streaming September 2nd
about two unlikely friends toying with
magic are you some kind of witch it's so
much fun being with these kids it really
reminded me how lucky we are to be doing
this and just be playing every day
foreign